fabien gilot bonjour merci de nous avoir
rejoints sur l'antenne de rtl france ce
matin alors plus de cent mille morts on
lisait les régions les plus touchées la
lombardie l'émilie romagne de piémont et
la vénétie vous vous attendez à des
semaines difficiles avec des éventuels
re confinement alors c'est une situation
un peu complexe à prendre sur le
territoire parce que la situation n'est
pas la même d'une région à l'autre
d'un côté nous avons des régions comme
le piémont la lombardie où les milieux
romagne actuellement qui sont très
touchées et d'autres côté vous avez la
sardaigne la sicile où la calabre qui
sont nettement moins touchées
actuellement la sardaigne est tourné en
zone blanche c'est à dire que la
sardaigne a retrouvé une vie quasi
normale alors que d'autres régions sont
extrêmement touchées ou le confinement
plane pour ces régionales
la situation est très variable d'un
territoire à l'autre et c'est ce qui va
compliquer aussi la tâche du
gouvernement
cent mille morts la barre des 100000
morts a été franchi comment est ce que
les italiens réagi ce matin
il ya beaucoup de deuil et bien sûr un
toute la presse italienne parle de ses
cent mille morts mais des visages sur
ces personnes à chaque région il ya des
éditions spéciales pour toute la presse
bien sûr c'est très important et
aujourd'hui c'est aussi rappeler à tous
les italiens que la situation n'est pas
terminé il faut continuer à travailler
dans le sens d'éliminer le caïd est donc
on va dire qu'il ya un grand moment de
recueillement
aujourd'hui dans la presse où est alors
un grand moment de recueillement mais
mais des mesures à prendre à vous le
disiez jusqu'ici c'est un peu plus de 5
millions de doses de
vaccins qui ont été administrées dans le
pays le président mario draghi s'est
fixée un d'accélérer la distribution des
vaccins cet axe est lié cette
accélération est ce qu'elle se fait déjà
sentir dans le pays
justement c'est vraiment l'objectif du
mois de la fin du mois de mars si
surtout du mois d'avril
mario draghi a été très silencieux ces
dernières semaines très peu entendu dans
la presse il a très peu fait d' annus il
a commencé hier en faire avec on va dire
un ton assez optimiste en général en
disant qu'une favre ont accéléré le
mouvement et objectifs seraient 1.25
million ou 50 millions de doses en avril
les chiffres concordent pas toujours
selon les sources
mais l'objectif ce serait ça peut-être
reconfirmer certaines régions ou ré
remettre des zones un peu plus rouge un
peu plus strictes un couvre-feu
peut-être plus tôt en italie mais dans
l'objectif d'accélérer au maximum et que
pour le mois d'avril et bien l'italie
serait quasi libérer de ce problème donc
il ya vraiment un sentiment est un désir
de la part du gouvernement et du
ministre de la santé sperenza
d'accélérer fortement et que avril soit
le mois de la vaccination
alors justement pour accélérer cette
vaccination il ya un accord qui a été
signé entre la russie et l'italie pour
produire les vaccins spoutnik vais sur
le territoire italien
c'est une des possibilités pour vacciner
rapidement et ce qu'est ce
mécontentement également en italie comme
on le voit en france sur les lenteurs de
l'europe
alors il ya plusieurs cas aussi parce
que c'est toujours un état régional donc
vous avez aussi des régions qui sont
plus rapides que d'autres ça c'est aussi
un problème que peuvent avoir les
italiens vous avez la province autonome
de bolzano à la frontière autrichienne
qui est très très en avance sur ses
vaccins la calabre au sud par exemple
qui est très en retard donc là aussi il
peut y avoir un sentiment parfois
demande d'égalité et d'équité sur le
territoire italien avant même de parler
de l'europe
mais c'est vrai que c'est une situation
comme pour les vaccins ou l'arrivée des
vaccins ou certaines régions ont décidé
de chercher par leurs propres moyens
c'est-à-dire qu'il eux ils vont
outrepasse rome il se repasse voxel
directement c'est le cas de la vénétie
par exemple où le gouverneur zahia
clairement c'est qu'il chercherait des
vaccins par ses propres moyens
alors vous êtes enseignant à
l'université de turin comment ça se
passe aujourd'hui pour vous
avec avec les étudiants c'est fermé tout
simplement l'université fermée pour
fermer depuis maintenant le mois
d'octobre
l'espoir de rouvrir avant la fin de
l'année est toujours présent parce qu'on
aimerait bien sûr retrouver ce contact
humain avec les étudiants ou ceux de la
première année qui arrive dans le monde
universitaire mais pour l'instant on va
dire que la réouverture pour le mois de
mars n'est pas du tout d'actualité et on
continuera à travailler bien sûr on lit
c'est compliqué à gérer pour les jeunes
comme c'est le cas notamment en france
écoutez ont peut-être peut-être encore
plus létal est un pays qui a un climat
une tradition de vivre à l'extérieur sur
les places
la traditionnelle promenade de
l'après-midi méridionale où de 5h à 7h
les personnes vont sortir et se promener
profiter des beaux jours les beaux jours
reviennent bien sûr que pour une
génération d'étudiants qui à 20 ans
aujourd'hui c'est ce n'est pas
formidable donc peut-être que c'est
vraiment ça l'objectif du gouvernement m
un dernier sacrifice pendant un mois
pour vraiment permettre à l'italie de
retrouver une vie qui est la sienne une
vie basée sur le tourisme sur la
restauration l'art la culture et la vie
en extérieur pour revenir sur la
question de la vaccination c'était
vendredi l'italie a bloqué l'exportation
de 250 mille doses vers l'australie
comment cette décision at elle été reçue
par l'opinion publique
et ça on en a parlé quand même pas tant
que ça dans la presse c'est un élément
qui est passé plus de l'aspect
diplomatique de l'aspect médical mais
l'italie est très liée aussi à
l'australie d'un point de vue historique
pour les migrations massives qu'il ya eu
des signes en australie donc c'est un
pays alliés dans lequel on veut
peut-être pas arrivé à trop de trouble
on va dire que cette situation n'a pas
eu de grandes grandes réactions parce
que justement c'est la situation de
l'australie reste t il un peu plus
marginale dans le rapport diplomatique
mais qui ne veut pas non plus faire trop
de vagues
oui alors l'aura pas confirmée 1 qu'
elle s'octroyait le droit de bloquer
certains accents en fonction des
priorités
on le rappelle l'australie a très peu de
cas donc
on peut comprendre aussi que l'italie
rang n'est plus besoin
la population la campagne de vaccination
comment ce père tel en italie est ce que
c'est au niveau régional que c'est
décidé oui alors il ya beaucoup de cas
c'est à dire de droit régional savez des
régions qu'ils ont des autonomies sony
ni autonomie la sicile le val d'aoste
par exemple donc là il ya bien sûr une
gestion régionale en général la santé et
gérer d'un point de vue régional en
italie donc chaque région se doit de
s'organiser
bien sûr il ya des lignes directrices il
ya des moyens bis au niveau national
vous l'avez montré dans votre reportage
c'est à dire l'installation de centres
de vaccination dans l'ensemble on peut
dire qu'il ya eu un énorme travail qui a
été fait sur tout le territoire italien
aussi bien pour des tests de co vide
dans les hôpitaux dans les gares que les
centres de vaccination d'une mise en
place d'un système très très important
les moyens ont été un très important
beaucoup de régions investies aussi même
temps du personnel par obtenir vraiment
résultats importants dans l'ensemble on
peut dire qu'aujourd'hui l'italie est
prête à l'action je pense et dans les
hôpitaux comment est-ce que ça se passe
c'est ce qu' ils sont saturés avec un
manque de personnel soignant
alors on a le problème vraiment de
grandes variations de région ou au
contraire les hôpitaux sont plutôt
calmes on va dire dans les îles
principalement sur les imageurs et vous
avez d'autres régions qui souffrent
énormément actuellement alors là aussi
le fait que le système sanitaire et de
santé soit organisée d'un point de vue
régional
ça pose le problème des certaines
régions qui ne sont pas toujours très
solidaire avec les autres donc vous avez
actuellement des régions déborder comme
l'émilie romagne la lombardie n'est pas
dans une très bonne situation le piémont
plus alors que vous avez d'autres
régions qui pourraient peut-être plus
facilement prendre des malades mais la
synergie entre les régions n'est pas
toujours très efficace
merci beaucoup fabien gilot d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct de turin donc
à nos questions sur arte france